after four days of intense fighting
finally some common streets of Aden but
also an accusation of betrayal from the
country's interior minister again
hundreds of vehicles landed in Aden are
fully loaded with weapons and ammunition
this is to combat mercenaries hired guns
who are being manipulated we are just
fighting with their hands with whatever
however we criticized the silence from
our brothers Saudi Arabia we condemn the
silence for four days while our partner
in the coalition is slaughtering us we
will meet you soon on the ground hours
later it was reported that the minister
had been evacuated from Aden to the
Saudi border town of sharira in Mecca
his government's leader was photographed
with the Saudi King but Albert Robbo
Mansour Hadi has lived in exile in Saudi
Arabia for years this latest battle for
Aden began Wednesday when southern
separatists backed by the UAE fought
against Saudi backed government soldiers
for control of the city by Saturday the
separatists had taken over the city's
presidential palace as well as several
military camps a ceasefire was called
that evening for the Eid holiday hours
later Saudi Arabia warned the
separatists to stop fighting then
followed that warning with airstrikes on
Aden central crater district in all at
least 40 people have been killed in the
latest fighting it's actually kind of
odd that you would have a ceasefire so
quickly because that allows the southern
separatists to consolidate their gains
rather than be ousted rather quickly and
so it's clear that Saudi Arabia believes
it can mediate and find a solution here
and I'm not so sure that they can do
that easily the UN's humanitarian
coordinator for Yemen says it's
heartbreaking the families are mourning
the deaths of their loved ones after
dozens of people killed since Wednesday
this flag represents a southern
separatists final goal to once again
create an independent state of South
Yemen
existed from 1967 until 1990 and the
recent fighting has exposed a rift in
the Saudi UAE military alliance that
have been at war with Houthi rebels
since 2015 but it may also open a new
front in a war that has killed tens of
thousands of people and it's pushed the
country to the brink of famine the
Roberta Manley al Jazeera